[Music]
welcome to this DW business special
asking the question what next for
Russia's population
Vladimir Putin started a war and back
home the Russian people are having to
cope with the consequences of it not
only are they feeling the effects of
international sanctions but thousands of
young Russian men are dying in Ukraine
hundreds of thousands of more have been
called up to the Army taking them away
from their jobs and their families
meanwhile many Russians have packed up
and started to leave the country
[Music]
so has President Putin put the country
on an unsustainable path or to answer
that question and hopefully many more
I'm joined by Oleg ichoki a Russian
Economist based at the University of
California Los Angeles thanks a lot for
joining us oh leg it's great to have you
with us
yeah hi Rob good to be with you
so the Russian population themselves are
coming under enormous strain as a result
of this War aren't they
uh yes there is no doubt about it the
way I would put it is that uh there was
a informal contract uh between the
government and the Russian population it
started as a country that the government
will deliver economic growth and the
population will not get involved into
politics uh would stay away would not be
interested in political process
elections and so on and indeed uh you
know the first couple of years of putum
he delivered you know five six seven
percent economic growth uh quickly
economic growth came to an end Russia
has not really been growing since 2008
since the crisis the growth rates on
average have been zero and the new
contract with the government was you
know you not get involved into Politics
as people as the population but we're
not going to get involved into your
private lives we're not going to
regulate your private lives uh you will
enjoy you know a steady stagnant you
know level of well-being but there's not
going to be major disruptions right and
so by 2022 this contract has changed
completely at this point it's not just
the usual corruption that Russians are
used to official corruption uh you know
you probably have heard in the news
about the scale of Russian corruption
it's really unheard of
um you know probably in the rest of the
world but now it's not just corruption
it's not just that the government steals
the economic well-being of people uh
it's you know and newly imposed tax on
human life right so since September 2022
uh the broad mobilization has started in
Russia which means that uh you know
young men between two 20 and 40 years
old mostly are being drafted for this
unjust brutal war in Ukraine and this is
really like a tax on human life right
this is something that Russians were not
um used to and this is just the new
reality
let's just talk about actually the
profound effect of the war that has been
the number of young men who are fighting
on behalf of Russia so as you mentioned
it was back in September that President
Putin announced the mobilization of 300
000 conscripts to help bolster Russian
numbers in Ukraine after Swift training
tens of thousands have already been
deployed to the front the mobilization
actually sparked rare protests in Russia
but the Kremlin claims that there will
be no further rounds of conscription
so I like itchy um how many young
Russian men is this war going to swallow
up before it's done
yeah to be clear we do not know the
numbers exactly right our best estimates
suggest uh that uh close to 300 000 of
young men have been mobilized
to be clear this this is after uh eight
nine months of War during which already
tens of thousands of Russians have died
right obviously I don't want to sound
like the major concern here is uh the
Russian casualties right it's a
completely unjust war in the territory
on Ukraine and uh you know similar
magnitudes uh of people have been tied
on died on the Ukrainian side and this
is a you know to me it's a much much
bigger concern among those people many
civilians uh but nonetheless tens of
thousands of Russian soldiers have died
up to September and since September it
was a broad mobilization
um of people people were taking at
random
mostly between 20 and 40 years old
probably uh uh 80 000 of these people
have been deployed and as far as we can
tell uh between 200 and 600 of this man
die daily right so it's a daily uh
deaths of hundreds
um so what is it what is the impact of
having so many young men dying on a
population and and on an economy like
Russia's
so to be clear right uh it's a country
with 140 million people
so many more hundred thousands in
principles could be mobilized and sent
to War uh also it's very important to
emphasize that there is no end of this
mobilization inside it it will keep
going I think it's very important not to
fool anyone and you know suggest that
maybe mobilization will stop at 300 000.
uh in fact now is the period of regular
Mobility regular uh draft right it's not
mobilization strictly speaking it's just
regular uh full seasonal draft uh which
will probably turn into winter
mobilization and so it's very clear to
keep in mind that as long as this war
continues the mobilization will continue
as well we don't know what's really
truly the capacity of the government how
many people they would be able to
mobilize before things will come to a
store but you know in all likelihood it
would be closer to a million people than
to uh a few hundred thousands more and
in that sense it's a you know it has a
sizable demographic effect it's also
very important emphasize that probably
more than a million people have left
Russia since the beginning of the war
which which is at this point another uh
important effect on the population and
lastly another thing that's very
important to emphasize is that you know
Russia to begin with was a country with
a very complex uh demographic structure
right it's a country that uh went
through a very deep demographic crisis
that started in the late 80s and lost it
through the 90s and as a result it's a
country where exactly the age cohort of
you know 25 to 35 year olds uh is very
thin to begin with right and in that
sense yes it is a major demographic
effect but it's hard to argue that
that's the most dire consequence of this
war for Russia well in indeed but um I
like just stay with us because I just
want to pick up on another thing you
mentioned now which is um a key
demographic impact of the the war in
Ukraine and that is the movement of
people that has been stimulated as a
result of the invasion of Ukraine this
uh in itself is changing the face of the
Russian population with hundreds of
thousands of Russians having left their
country you said around a million in
recent months mostly Bound for
Kazakhstan it seems some to avoid the
mobilization to the army of course
meanwhile in the other direction Russia
says almost 3 million ukrainians have
crossed the border into Russia the West
says that ukrainians are being forcibly
deported there by the Russian army oh
like among the countries where sorry
actually oh like I'll come back to you
in a second I just want to play a clip
of something actually because among the
countries where Russians have fled uh is
Mongolia and our reporter out there
power and Wang has been explaining what
it's like there
local people told us that after Russian
President Vladimir Putin announced the
partial mobilization the city was filled
with Russians according to the statistic
by the end of October they are about
1500 Russians had fled to ulambatar and
most of them are ethnic minorities
delegates koki from UCLA what is this
Exodus from Russia say about the
attitude of Russians towards the war
yeah no it's it's completely incredible
there is no active military action on
the territory of Russia at least on the
internationally recognized territory of
Russia and you have more than a million
people living in less than a year this
is completely unprecedented uh uh you
know people do leave to all countries
where they can go obviously it's a very
tough choice because a lot of people
abandon uh their property abandon their
jobs and they they just flee and again
going back to the beginning of our
conversation it's a sign of this change
in contract with the government where
the government promised not to uh get
involved in the personal lives of people
if they stay away from politics but now
uh the government comes for you know
lives of many many Russians and Russians
flee from this but again if we think
about you know the future term the
extent of uncertainty of what's going to
happen with Russia as a country is uh
dramatic right uh in Russia can fall
apart as a country as a result of this
war Russia can go into complete
otaki which is a Soviet style or North
Korea style or turkey right and in that
sense uh perhaps the life being of
people who are living now will be much
better than if they if they choose to
stay and they think that's that's one of
the imaginations why people are leaving
that they see that Putin is tightening
his grip on power becoming more
autocratic and they fear for what's next
we do have data for this now right so we
did see that people left in a very large
wave when the war started in February
but most of those people actually did
come back so what people were afraid was
first and foremost this mobilization is
the fact that they would be sent to War
uh it's very clear now that the second
wave of uh departures is bigger and
people are not coming back right and so
we clearly understand that uh it's
mostly not the economic reasons that
drive people it's mostly they fear for
life right that the fact they can be
mobilized in a very very near term of
course I mean people are here
potentially being not as farsighted as
they should be because they're a very
clear Prospect for Russia is Decades of
isolation Titan gripped at home
repression at home this is all in the
cards but I don't think uh it's uh quite
as you know clear in the minds of people
as this this very Cardinal risk of you
know being drafted been sent to war
you know like the movement in in the
other direction that I mentioned some
three million uh I think Moscow says 2.8
million ukrainians have have crossed the
border into Russia since the invasion
opponents claim that that is something
that's very deliberate by Russia why
would Russia be doing that if it was
indeed doing it on purpose
well to be very clear uh it's a
absolutely brutal war on the Ukrainian
territory so if we take the city of
marupal it was a city of nearly half a
million people which was uh pretty much
entirely destroyed big parts of this
population had no choice but to flee in
the in the Eastern direction to cross
the border into Russia that many of
these ukrainians are trying to find ways
to leave Russia obviously it's
completely unbearable for most of them
uh and so in that sense I I'm not sure
if we have very uh precise data here on
how many ukrainians actually moved to
Russia and stayed there but in all
likelihood this is you know numbers of
the orders of magnitude of half a
million to a million people
uh I would particularly try uh emphasize
the fact that a lot of kids are being
relocated and to me this is not as much
a theme you know of demographics as it's
you know a fact that emphasizes the
genocidal nature of this war right that
it's it's really uh a war that
um is doing uh some Terrible Things the
Ukrainian population uh separating
parents from children sending children
uh into random places in the Russian
territory and this is one of the war
crimes uh that we're facing and I would
emphasize this along with the
concentration camps that Russia is
introducing in many of the occupied
territories where you know just the mere
fact that somebody
um has a symbol of Ukraine for example a
tattoo with a uh Ukrainian emblems right
that would be a reason to torture and
kill the person right and so this is
2022 and we're talking a bit again about
concentration camps
in Europe and to me this is really uh
the most Stark pictures of this war then
you know if we turn to demographics uh
just seems like a secondary issue but
indeed there is this uh massive flows of
uh people I would emphasize four million
ukrainians that left to the West right
this is the biggest displacement of
population in Europe since the Second
World War uh right and so it's very hard
to say how it will play over the years I
mean we're in a
state of humongous uncertainty where
it's not clear what will happen to
Russia as a country if we look two years
ahead and this demographic issues this
is something that will persist uh but
you know the displaced populations in
Russia this hardly will be uh the first
topic of concern if uh you know the the
whole fate of Russia is so uncertain in
the next couple of years
actually something that you you
mentioned there which is about the the
disproportionate number of of children
that are being taken across into Russia
according to the Ukrainian government we
can actually hear from president
zielinski on that very issue We Know by
name eleven thousand children who were
forcibly deported to Russia they were
separated from their parents in full
knowledge that they have families apart
from the children we know about there
are tens of thousands of others who were
forcibly deported and about whom we know
only indirectly
and we've been talking about the impact
on the Russian population but obviously
it's a much more profound impact on the
Ukrainian population and you know you
can talk about demographics but that's
that's the the least of the their
problems really but I just want to sort
of wrap up on talking about the
situation in Russia how severe could the
impact of all of this be for Russia is
it on a path that is unsustainable now
well it just dramatic uncertainty of
what may happen going forward right and
you cannot exclude any possible
scenarios at this point
um there is a possibility that Russia
falls apart as a country there is a
possibility of a Civil War uh there is a
possibility of uh some sort of more
orderly political transition when uh
Putin loses power and whoever is the
next person who comes to it stops the
war this is also a possibility it's very
difficult to put probabilities on all
those different scenarios it is all in
the cards as of now I think it's
imperative that all countries in the
world especially countries in Europe uh
do everything for uh the victory of
Ukraine in this war and this means both
military help and economic pressure on
Russia because these are the only two
ways how this work uh can really end uh
you know nobody should fool themselves
and think that some type of a temper a
ceasefire is the way to the end of this
war
um Russia needs to leave Ukraine and we
don't know how it will happen but this
is the only possible tonight or for how
this war ends and then there is a big
question what happens in Russia after
that and it's you know important next to
impossible to predict uh where you know
can view it multiple scenarios here the
the most
uh the uh the most benign of this uh is
some political collapse a new political
regime uh without a Civil War and
without Russia collapsing into pieces
that would be the most uh benign
scenario in this case uh in fact what I
view as the last benign scenario is that
Russia goes into isolation the political
regime is preserved and we see something
like a Soviet Union to zero which looks
much more like uh something between Iran
and North Korea and that to me is one of
a very sad uh possible scenarios for
Russian population in fact
it's a very Stark prediction from a Lego
ex-corky there from UCLA thank you very
much for joining us on the program I
would like it's been a pleasure
absolutely
thanks also for you who've been watching
us wherever you are be sure to check out
our previous specials here on the DW
news YouTube channel they're all worth a
watch until next time take care